apparently there's a truce in the war of
the Windsors at least for now only et
has exclusive details from inside the
family meeting I am here as you know for
all the royalty and so our guest co-host
FBI's most wanted star kilowatt and I'm
on the case here's everything we know
about the Queen's emergency royal summit
the Queen has given her blessing for the
couple to quit life as members of the
royal family
there's been no talk of stripping their
titles we understand the meeting was
about three hours and Prince William in
a signal of just how strained the
relationship is now between the brothers
didn't arrive until 15 minutes before
that meeting started at 2:00 o'clock the
meeting was wrapped by five and each of
the principals William Harry and the
Prince of Wales were seen leaving
Sandringham in separate cars
we're told Megan may have called or
facetimed into the meeting so she could
address the Queen herself our source
says the biggest argument is over money
and how things will work one question
who pays for security and all their
travel one thing is for sure Megan and
Harry have made that shock decision and
are standing by it to step down as
senior members of the royal family this
is a seismic transition in the royal
family the Queen did reveal Megan and
Harry will live in Canada and the UK not
LA where Megan's mother lives and where
the former actress could reignite her
career one of Megan's first jobs Disney
may be over the weekend this remarkable
footage of Harry and Megan emerge
it's from the London premiere of The
Lion King last year while Megan chats
with jay-z and Beyonce Harry can be
heard telling Disney CEO Bob Iger that
Megan does voice over work
[Music]
when we watch that video that is
absolutely extraordinary here is Harry
basically promoting and offering his
wife out for business and I think it's
this sort of commercialization of the
Royals that sends alarm bells ringing at
the palace but Hollywood hey it loves a
good pitch and has a message for Megan
is there a role for her and this is a
why not very brave I like her in front
of the camera before she became royalty
so you know it's kind of like one of
those like Grace Kelly stories like
grace is a fantastic actor so I think
you know embrace the guy who spent time
in this business why not
[Music]